all right let's hit the headlines first
up we have got to talk about pop star
meghan trainor and her bathroom
because it's the story everybody's
talking about it really is everywhere if
you're on like instagram or social media
this is the story that keeps coming up
glamour reports that megan says she and
her husband actor daryl sabara have side
by side his and her toilets that's right
she says they're number one together all
the time but as far as number two
they've only tried that once oh god um
yes this is what they're saying so let's
discuss chelsea ross thought uh oh god
i like that they've only tried number
two once it's like exactly yeah
they're not gonna try that twice no you
don't you don't go back for more of that
you know i'm yeah i'm a romantic so i'm
trying to find the a separate bathroom
no i'm trying
yes
i'm thinking
is there something sweet about this you
know i mean you're sitting there or
standing there and you turn to your
partner and you say
you know you're
you're my number one
is there's something sweet about it
yeah i mean i love megan so i want to
support her and her decision making uh i
don't think i need to do that i feel
like you can feel the effects of that
just by living in close spaces that you
don't need to drive that point home
totally but i am the biggest meghan
trainor fan and she is a nantucket girl
i am obsessed with her megan please come
on the show i love you so much i am
cheering you on always
i am yeah okay ross
except for this whole two toilet things
girl no
call the contractor i think she's gotten
the message loud and clear
i think she put this out there and then
probably that's what i want to come on
the show i want to ask you like are you
glad you put this out there i just think
this is sort of a crappy idea all right
all right next another love story and
this one's a little bit different it
comes from oprah daily jim who's 78 and
audrey who's 79 met last fall on this
website called silver singles for people
dating over 50 years old
jim was new to it and his wife had
passed in 2017 and audrey she'd been on
on it for years with no luck well guess
what they were a match 94
match so they spent the first 10 nights
just gabbing on facetime i guess they
asked their grandkids how to facetime
and then they moved on to covid safe
dating and three months later they moved
in and five months later jim proposed
with his mom's 1939 art deco ring
and last month love birds they were
married in front of friends and family
and for their honeymoon they say they're
going to stay in and watch their
favorite detective shows oh god
can i marry you
i have to tell you
my grandma after my grandpa passed away
her boyfriend from elementary school at
91 tracked her down and until harv
passed away they were sort of courting
and they found like romance again at 91
and i remember thinking god you know if
i ever find myself
old and single you know i'm gonna leave
a little tray next to that side of the
bed for somebody's dentures just in case
because you
you gotta keep the love alive the hope
for love alive don't you well i mean i
would suggest i guess the next question
for these two is what their toilet
situation is you know what i mean
what's keeping their love alive
i love when elderly people find love you
know what an inspiration for everybody
it's so sweet and singles what's it
called silver city singles silver
singles thank you very much
by the way it should be called silver
city singles here i take umbrage with 50
as a silver single yeah yeah that part
we take umbrage with it because we're
about to round the corner of that number
exactly when we were young it's like 50
is so old now we're like 50 is the new
20.
what about you chelsea would you ever
consider um
marrying me uh well you know i take a
lot of pride in remaining not married
you know i just feel like it's an
antiquated notion and it's a structure
set up by what i just feel like it's
outdated to be quite honest well fair
but
you have changed your mind about a lot
of things as you've grown oh i'm sure
i'll get married next week or something
every time i say i'm not going to do
something the next week i'm like oh here
i go again
um i said like a few years ago i'm like
i'll never write another book and then
the next week i was like okay i'm ready
to write a book so i think i just have
to say i'm not doing something and i'll
do it so you can't rely on me for the
truth about my own situation
they say never say never well you've
been you're good at marrying you got
three would you ever get married again
never
ever it doesn't work for me i it's like
i've tried it and you know you it just
no
i would i would also like to add that i
would like to send a message to all
women and and all people really that are
growing up that that doesn't make you
valuable you know what i mean being
married doesn't give you an identity
that you didn't previously had i think
it's a really strong um
strong stance to show people that you
can have it all you can be in love you
can have success you can have your
career and love your family and there
doesn't have to be a label to it
completely you can define what love and
happiness and success is for you yeah so
i think that's important especially for
young girls i love that
[Music]